(bright music)
- Our goal is really to be able to detect
reckless and dangerous drivers
before they get to the intersection.
And to do that, we use
recurrent neural networks
to actually deploy and train our networks
in a scaled autonomous vehicle platform
called the MiniCity.
We use real hardware
but scaled to a 1/10 scale size
to deploy all of our autonomy
and to be able to detect when
there's a dangerous driver
at an intersection.
Typically, there's two paradigms,
you either have full scale vehicles,
which are pretty dangerous
and expensive to actually
deploy your algorithms
or you do it purely in simulation,
which is probably the
most popular these days
in the industry.
We're using a scaled physical platform
so we can actually really see
how these work in the real world
interacting with real
hardware, sensors, delays,
the things you actually see
when you deploy these
autonomous vehicles on the road.
Safety in general is a
really hard thing to monitor
but what's novel about our approach
is that we're actually
using the traffic lights
to observe drivers on the road.
And in doing so, we try and
detect from outside of the car
whether there's a failure occurring
and actually warn other
vehicles ahead of time.
We looked at four
different types of failures
that we actually deploy
on our scaled hardware.
The first one is just random
noise that we add and inject
into the low level steering
and speed of the vehicle.
And this is to simulate
just a random error
that happens in your autonomy stack.
Second one is a failure in
the perception of the vehicle
so how it detects the scenes around it.
The third one, we have a speeding driver,
so this is to simulate
a reckless human driver
or just, again, another
failure in the autonomy stack.
And then, finally, we
actually brought human drivers
into the MiniCity
so we can actually test
out with real human driving
to show what a reckless
driver might look like.
We wanna actually look over time,
can we see the pattern
and really the causal nature
of whether there's a failure
occurring in the driver.
So RNN lets us really pinpoint,
what is the state of this driver,
and using both the current driving style
of the driver of the vehicle,
but also the history of the trajectory
we've seen in the past of the vehicle.
Each of the vehicles has the hardware
you would find on a full scale car,
so we have lidar, we have
cameras, we have IMUs,
and we also have the onboard compute.
So we have a computer onboard
and it's ingesting all that information
with the software we've developed
so that they could drive autonomously
and we can put new neural networks,
new algorithms on our cars to test them.
We go from developing
software on our computers,
put them on the computers,
on the cars themselves,
they collect sensor data,
and then it comes up with a decision
on the actual speed that the
wheels of the cars can turn
and actually the angle on
the steering of the cars.
And kind of the dream
is we would have these
intelligent intersections
and traffic lights that
actually could be a safety net
for if there's some type of failure
that occurs in your car with the driver
or even with your software.
We're always going to have failures,
and if we can use the
AI to actually predict
these types of collisions
before they happen,
hopefully, we can have
much, much safer roads
for us to drive on.